- [Voiceover] It is given
that and they give us
the sine, cosine and tangent of 70 degrees
or at least they give us the
first few digits of them.
And then they get into the
meat of this actual diagram
and the diagram above angle ABC
and angle BCD are right angles.
Now they show us that right over here.
This is angle ABC, angle BCD
and then they say that AC,
segment AC is parallel to BD.
AC is parallel to BD
and AB is parallel to CD.
AB is parallel to CD
and all of that looks
the way it was drawn.
It looks like they're parallel as well
but it's nice that they're telling us that
otherwise we can't really assume that.
Which of the following is
closest to the length of AB
and they give us some choices here.
Let's think about it.
They give us, we have
a 70-degree angle here
and they've given us the sine,
cosine and tangent of 70 degrees.
It feels like we should be
able to use that somehow.
Actually if they were asking us
for the length of side CD,
if they were asking us
for the length of side CD
we could immediately
apply our trigonometry.
Because for this bottom right triangle,
this triangle BCD we could apply
the SOHCAHTOA definition of cosine,
which just remind ourselves.
SOHCAHTOA.
Sine of an angle is
opposite over hypotenuse.
Cosine of an angle is
adjacent over hypotenuse.
Tangent of an angle is
opposite over adjacent.
Well, over here for BCD,
triangle BCD for this
triangle right over here,
we know the hypotenuse.
We know the hypotenuse,
we know the angle
and if we were trying to figure out
what CD was equal to
well, we would need to figure
out what the adjacent side is
and I coul just call that lower case a.
That would be the adjacent side.
So what deals with
adjacent and a hypotenuse?
Well cosine deals with
adjacent and hypotenuse
and if any of these looks
completely foreign to you,
I encourage you to watch
the basic trigonometry
videos on Khan Academy.
But we know that the cosine of 70 degrees
would be equal to the
length of the adjacent side
over the length of the hypotenuse.
Over 8.9
or if you multiply both sides by 8.9
you have 8.9 times the
cosine of 70 degrees
is equal to the length
of this adjacent side,
and they tell us what the
cosine of 70 degrees is.
It's 0.3420.
So you'd have 8.9
times 0.3420.
If (mumbles) need to write that last zero.
It keeps going on and on.
Actually let me just write it there.
I'll just write the
first couple of digits.
That's going to be
approximately equal to a.
This isn't exactly the
cosine of 70 degrees
but it's a pretty, it's
reasonably accurate.
And so, if we look at this,
this is roughly, this is almost eight
and this is a little bit more
or sorry, this is almost nine,
and this is a little
bit more than a third.
A little bit a third
of nine would be three.
This should be, I don't know
I'm guessing a little bit,
you know, around three.
If you look at the choices,
well there is a choice.
Whoops.
There is a choice that looks
right around where we need.
None of these other values
are even close to three.
If we were trying to figure out,
if we were trying to figure out
the length of CD we'd be done.
I would say I would just pick,
I would just pick this
choice right over here.
But we're not asked just the length of CD,
we're asked the length of AB
and you might say, "Hey look,
the way this figure is drawn,
"AB looks to be the
exact same length as CD."
And maybe if you're under time pressure
you might be able to make that leap
and just go ahead with it
and bad things would not happen.
But if you want to be a little
bit more rigorous about it,
a little bit more sure,
you'd probably want to
prove it to yourself
and that's where the
parallel lines come in value.
Because what we're gonna do is
we're gonna prove that triangle BCD,
what I've shaded in blue
is congruent to triangle ABC.
We're gonna prove that they're congruent.
We're gonna prove that they're congruent
by showing that they have,
that their corresponding
angles are congruent
and that they have at
least one congruent side.
The side that they share right over here.
They both share this side.
They both share that side.
Let's prove that all of their angles,
their corresponding angles are congruent.
They both already have one right angle
and we can prove that
corresponding angles are congruent
by extending some of these parallel lines.
I was thinking about
transversals and parallel lines.
If those words I just
told you make no sense
I encourage you to watch the videos
on angles and transver...
Transversals and parallel
lines on Khan Academy.
The first thing is I want to
see if I can establish that
this thing up here, that angle BAC,
that this is also 70 degrees.
It looks like it but I'd like to prove it.
One thing I could do is I could extend.
Let me do it this way.
So if I extended this line like that
and if I extend it, I'm
just doing this to help the,
help you visualize the
transversal of parallel lines.
And then if I extend this line,
this line like this.
Now you see that if you're
thinking about line CD
it is a transversal across
these two parallel lines.
When you look at it that
way you see that this angle
corresponds to this angle right over here.
If this angle is 70 degrees
then this angle is also
going to be 70 degrees.
Now if that angle is 70 degrees
now let's think about...
Now let's make AC into a transversal.
Let me do something.
Let me do it like this.
Let me draw, let me extend this line.
Let me extend this
just so you see how the lines intersect
and I could even extend to this one.
Whoops, that's not what I wanted to do.
Let me extend that one a little bit.
It looks like this.
And so you see, AC is a transversal
for the line AB and the line CD.
Now we know alternate
interior angles are congruent
and this one is an
alternate interior angle
with this one right over here.
This is 70 degrees then
this too must be 70 degrees.
So now you've established.
This angle is 90, this angle is 90.
This angle is 70, this angle is 70.
Well if two angles of a
triangle are congruent,
the third angle is going to be congruent.
All three of them have
to add up to 180 degrees
so this thing right over here.
This thing right over, let
me just do a different color.
This thing right over here,
that's going to be 180 minus 90 minus 70.
180 minus 90 is 90, minus 70 is 20.
That's going to be 20 degrees
and by the exact same logic
this is also, this one also
is going to be 20 degrees.
180 minus 90 minus 70.
20 degrees.
So, both of these triangles,
all of their interior angles are the same.
Their corresponding interior
angles are congruent.
That by itself would make them similar
but then one of the corresponding sides,
we know that that is congruent.
Between the angles being congruent
and then the side being congruent,
we know that the triangles
themselves are congruent.
If the hypotenuse of this, of BCD is 8.9
then the hypotenuse of ABC
is also going to be 8.9.
And now figuring out the length of AB,
figuring out the length of AB
is exactly the same thing
as figuring out the length of C,
is the same thing as the length of CD.
These are corresponding sides.
And since the triangles are congruent,
the length of AB is going
to be the same thing
as the length of CD
which is of course 3.04.
This is what we started solving
at the beginning of the video.
Now I wouldn't normally
suggest this to you
but you know, if you're taking a test
and if you're under time pressure,
there is a, you know...
Well, this one actually was
drawn fairly close to scale.
I don't know if you would actually see,
this was a sample item we constructed
but this one, well anyway, I
won't go too much into that.